50 years ago today dr. know debuted on
movie screens in London and in three
weeks time the 23rd official film based
on the exploits of James Bond agent
double-oh 7 will open there it's the
longest-running franchise in movie
history it's lasted through six
different James Bond's and weathered
colossal changes in both moviemaking and
the geopolitical climate that originally
spawned Ian Fleming's literary creation
but mainly it's all been great fun a
British secret agent were the licence to
kill a penchant for vodka martinis and
beautiful women not necessarily in that
order
but always accompanied by great music
memorable title songs powerfully
effective scores and one theme in
particular that has become truly iconic
recognized the world over sometimes just
for its opening bassline the James Bond
theme which we heard at the outset was
written by London's songwriter monty
norman as part of his score for dr. know
he had been to Jamaica with the crew in
January 1962 and recorded a lot of music
there but he was back in London before
he came up with a signature tune for his
hero he pulled an old unused song out of
a drawer dropped the lyrics sped it up a
little and voila ding-ding-ding dundun
dundun dundun but as we will hear
shortly and firsthand from our guitarist
friend Vic flick it took arranger
Orchestrator John Berry to turn that
sketch into the dark and dangerous sound
that became the familiar theme for James
Bond John Barry was an up-and-coming
young composer who had already enjoyed
several instrumental hits with his group
the John Barry seven he had become music
director at London's EMI records and was
starting to do movies with titles like
beat girl or as it was titled here in
America wild for kicks
don't you just want to see that movie
after doctor no and success on the
record charts for his arrangement of the
monty norman theme barry was invited to
write the music for the second Bond film
From Russia With Love and it was so
effective so atmospheric that Barry not
only got to write the score but also the
song for the third double-oh-seven film
Goldfinger along with his old friends
Anthony newley and Leslie brick as' to
write the words Michael Caine who was
crashing at Barry's flat at the time
tells a funny story about being kept up
all night while Barry was pounding out
Goldfinger at the piano believe it or
not the Goldfinger soundtrack went to
number one in the United States pushing
both the Mary Poppins soundtrack and the
Beatles 65 album out of the top spot for
three consecutive weeks that's how
popular this music was and it helped
catapult John Barry into the limelight
as well within two years he would have
his first two academy awards for best
song and best score for born free a
movie about lions in Africa that
couldn't be farther removed from the
world of James Bond but first there was
another bond to score and in some ways
this was the most complicated job of all
the next film was Thunder ball and once
again the composing assignment fell to
John Barry this time he invited one of
his Goldfinger colleagues Leslie brick
as' to co-write a song that would be
called mr. Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
after a phrase he'd been told was a
popular Italian nickname for Bond
it went like this he's tall and he's
dark and like a shark he looks for
trouble that's why the zeros double Mr
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang thank you very much
bond producers cubby broccoli and Harry
Saltzman gave their okay they wrote the
song berry based his entire score on
this theme and they went into the studio
with none other than Dionne Warwick to
sing it a very successful recording and
they all thought they had another Bond
hit on their hands until United Artists
decided it didn't want a song called mr.
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang on the radio they
wanted a song called Thunder ball